then we understand from doing our own
research and hopefully this is crowd
chatter okay that you were an intern for
Def Jam right I was that's right okay
and then we see that in turning in this
quote new economy is sort of this new
career path and sometimes it seems to be
working for people and sometimes there's
been backlash because there's 40 year
old guys college degrees in turning and
then they're not paid what would you say
to a person that wants to intern and
then turn it into a paying career what
would you say are some of the do's and
don'ts I would say when you sign up for
an internship to be completely open and
to be incredibly hard-working obviously
right and I interned at Def Jam but I'm
working in the record business but I
will attribute my success in my career
to that internship because I was open I
made relationships and one thing led to
another and it got me to where I am
today so I would say go into it thinking
that I this is a this is my entry this
is my me walking in the door but i don't
know if i'm going to turn left I don't
know if I'm gonna turn right I don't
know if I'm gonna walk back out the door
and go through another door I started
interning at Def Jam when I was 18 or 19
there I met a woman who was a host of a
syndicated music show she also worked in
Def Jam I began producing segments on
this syndicated show that was in six
markets at the time I was well then I
became about 20 and I was filming the
segment's I was editing the segment's I
was booking the the guests and the
locations producing all aspects of these
little segments on the syndicated show
then it became a nationally syndicated
shows like a hundred markets the woman
who was the host of the show with a
little crazy when the show got a little
bigger they needed a host I stepped in
in my first interviews with Dave
Chappelle on the set of his comedy
central show before season 1 launch and
then I started doing junkets for the
show I made a real i got it to mtv they
gave me a job my first on-camera
interview was with with will smith and
angelina jolie and Jack Black on MTV
never going to
before that was crazy and then it just
led me that I worked in and beasts and
just from there found my way but I
attributed back to being a deaf gym and
just being open and being you know down
for anything if you surround yourself
with good people good things will happen
i remember reading this will smith quote
where he said anybody who's looking to
change their life or the only different
path take a look at the five people you
spend the most amount of time with
that's a real reflection of yourself and
so I say it to anybody who wants to take
on an internship surround yourself with
good people at that internship when you
get a job and if you're an intern on a
movie set who are the other interns
there because you're gonna kind of come
up as a class in a lot of ways almost
like high school or something so I found
that I mean for me when I was starting
out on TV and a consistent consistent
job at the e-channel hang being with
cats Adler and Sal Masekela and Ryan
Seacrest and Jason Kennedy these are
really there the television
professionals I'm some kid from New York
who likes hip-hop and wear sneakers like
they may be like wow like I'm in the big
leagues I gotta step my game up so I
learned a lot from them um I don't know
I feel like if you just surround
yourself with good people then good
things will happen and this business I
mean that that's that's more true than a
lot of others I feel like you know you
look at someone like I don't know like
that like a Seth Rogen and Judd Apatow
and jonah hill and jason segel and that
whole crew you know they surround
themselves with each other and it kind
of brings them all up you know you see
that a lot so anybody who's looking for
an internship find something that will
some you'll meet some interesting people
and some good people because then that
could take you a million different ways
that makes sense yeah I was an internal
in the mailroom at the William Morris
Agency when I was a senior in high
school and had the suit on the mail
cards gets creamed on by agents but some
of the other interns in the mailroom
were cool guys and I met
m and we kind of came up together and
ten years later one of them is my agent
at Wave are so I i if you never know
where your life is going to take you if
you're just open to to where it could go
then good things are happening I see a
lot of interns I've seen over the years
at different places I've worked they
show up late they leave early they don't
talk to anybody else they say well I'm
not getting paid well there's no
positions even if I what's my
internships over there's nowhere for me
to get hired here but you never know
where people are gonna work I mean there
was a girl her name is ashlan gorse and
she was my producer when I was a
freelance guest on an MSNBC movie show
now she's an e channel correspondent and
we sat next to each other for four years
and worked together on air did live
events together and it's like you never
know where people's careers are going to
go so just be open and then hopefully
you know you put yourself in good
situations I yes
you